when Bill O'Reilly left no one's going
to replace Bill O'Reilly everybody said
to say oh it's going to be done game
over Megan Kelly oh nobody just it's
done it's over Tucker Carlson oh well
it's done it's over what is different
Jed about Tucker than when it happened
with Megan than when it happened with
O'Reilly I don't know that it's Tucker I
think it's the time and I think it's the
awareness that people have of what
corporate media is and I think it's the
options that they have so it was a time
where you didn't have a lot of options
you turned on the TV that's what you saw
people would I mean I know like my
parents even old school put the TV on
you watch the news you shut it off
that's your option now with podcasting
with Twitter streaming with Rumble with
VT with all of these options people are
now seeing what corporate media